When you were a child,
what did you want to be when you grew up?
A footballer?
An actress?
A doctor?
Well, when I was a little girl,
whenever I was asked the question,
my answer was pretty much always the same:
"When I grow up, I want to become a man."
To my logic, that was the only way
I could live a life
free from the suffocating restrictions
that women in my birth country
of Iran were forced to endure.
I'm not quite sure where this
line of thinking started from,
but a particularly hot summer's
afternoon comes to mind.
I was nine years old
and along with my family,
as we did on every summer holiday,
we had traveled to the north of Iran
to a little seaside village
called Chamkhaleh.
For as long as I remember,
some of my best childhood memories
are of me swimming in the Caspian Sea,
paddling in its waves
and making sandcastles
on its gorgeous beaches.
All of those lovely memories, though,
were about to be rewritten.
In the Islamic Republic of Iran,
when a girl turns nine years old,
she has legally entered womanhood.
And that means having to follow a series
of restrictive rules written by men.
The most symbolic of which is probably
the mandatory wearing of the hijab.
That year, my mom had to sit me down
and sorrowfully explain
that I was now too old
to get into the water wearing a swimsuit.
Now that I was nine years old,
it was illegal.
And if I wanted to get into the water
like all the other women,
I had to go in fully covered
from head to toe.
I had to go in wearing a pair of trousers,
a long-sleeved top and a loose covering
called the manto to cover it all.
And of course, the headscarf.
I still remember the lump in my throat
as I set foot in the water.
I could no longer feel the fresh coolness
of the Caspian Sea against my skin.
Instead, my now-wet layers
felt itchy and weird.
I can still remember feeling the watchful
eyes of the morality police,
the so-called morality police,
making sure that me and the other girls
were not showing too much hair
or too much skin to,
God forbid, arouse the men.
It was as if my former freedoms
were washing away
with every tide and flow of the water.
Next, I'm deep in the water.
I was a good swimmer, but my layers
were so heavy and restrictive.
I tried to gasp for air,
but my headscarf kept blocking my face.
The tides were pulling me
further and further out.
I could see my mom and dad on the beach,
I tried to call for help,
but they couldn't hear me.
Perhaps my voice was drowned out
by the roaring engines of the bikes
that the morality police
were patrolling the beaches.
The tides continued, pulling
me further and further out
and hopelessness started creeping in.
Next, I wake up on the beach,
cold, wet, shivering.
It turns out my father had just
spotted my struggles in time
and had rushed in to get me.
That was the last time
I ever set foot in my beloved Caspian Sea.
Growing up in the Islamic
Republic of Iran,
every day it felt as though I was going
through the same experience
but in different ways.
And looking at the women in my life,
they seemed to be going through the same
thing too, in different ways.
And the older I grew,
the further out the tides
of oppression, injustice, inequality
felt like they were pulling me in.
Wherever I turned,
shame, fear and especially
hopelessness were ever-present.
Women in Iran are second-class citizens.
They have almost no access
when it comes to some
of the most basic rights like divorce,
custody of children and even travel.
They have no legal protection
against sexual harassment
and domestic violence.
They are not allowed to sing in public
or have sex outside of marriage,
and they're only allowed to show
their face and hand in public.
In the 20 years or so
since I almost drowned,
nothing has changed.
Iranian women have been adrift
in a vast sea of oppression.
Their only way out, for those who could,
is to leave themselves at the mercy
of people smugglers,
set out on dangerous journeys
in hope of finding safety
in a land far away.
That's what happened to me.
Age 12, along with my mom
and my baby sister,
we escaped Iran.
And after years of living
in refugee camps across Europe,
sleeping rough
and being at the mercy of some
very, very dodgy people smugglers,
we finally found
safe haven here, in the UK.
For my friends and family
who stayed behind,
there was little hope for change.
And so when in September last year,
22-year-old Mahsa Jina Amini
stepped out of the metro
onto the bustling streets of Tehran,
there was little reason to expect
a change to the status quo.
The same way that it's happened to my own
mother and many other women I know,
Mahsa was arrested
by the so-called morality police
because, in their opinion,
she was showing more hair
than they deemed acceptable.
Three days later,
Mahsa died in police custody.
This time, though, something changed.
Thanks to the power of social media
and the brave journalists
working hard on the ground,
the news of Mahsa's killing
wasn't drowned out
in the regime's relentless propaganda.
In the same way
that the unjust killing of George Floyd
ignited the Black Lives Matter movement,
the unjust killing of Mahsa Amini
ignited the biggest anti-regime
protests across Iran
since the formation
of the Islamic Republic in 1979.
For the first time in decades,
women in Iran are finally daring
to defy the strict morality laws.
In a fight for equality and dignity,
they are taking off their headscarves,
burning them in bonfires,
and some are cutting off their hair.
They're chanting "Zan. Zendegi. Azadi."
"Woman, Life, Freedom."
Furious crowds are calling for democracy,
for freedom of speech,
for freedom of expression,
whilst many others are calling
for the fall of the supreme leader,
Ali Khamenei.
Khamenei is Iran's spiritual leader
and has the final say
over all government matters.
For the first time
in a very, very long time,
there seems to be hope in the air.
Hope that perhaps change
in Iran is possible.
And that's exactly why the crackdown
has been so brutal and deadly.
These are the faces of the protesters
who fought for freedom
but will not live to see it.
Since the protest began
nearly five months ago,
around 500 people have been killed.
Nearly 80 of those children.
Around 18,000 protesters
have been arrested.
And there are reports of psychological,
physical and sexual torture in prisons.
There has been a series of hasty trials,
forced confessions
and public executions of the protesters.
The authoritarian regime of Iran
is clearly desperate
to kill any and all hope
because they know that for as long
as we remain hopeless,
we'll resign to their
oppression and injustice.
But as history has shown
over and over again,
the light of hope emerges
from the depth of darkness.
Hope is angry.
It's defiant.
Hope is dangerous.
Hope is standing its ground
on the streets of Iran,
chanting "Woman, Life, Freedom."
Hope is in political prisons,
biding its time,
sustaining those in shackles.
Hope has now spread to the four
corners of my birth country.
As a journalist, I can't travel to Iran.
But as my sisters in Tehran, Mashhad,
Shiraz, Baluchistan, Kurdistan,
shomal, jonoob, shargh, gharb,
all over Iran have done,
I, too,
I'm going to cut my hair
to show my solidarity with the movement.
(Cheers and applause)
(Cheers and applause continues)
Thank you.
(Applause continues)
(Applause ends)
Thank you.
Audience: Freedom for women!
(Cheers)
SZ: This hair, for too long, has been
intertwined with religion and politics.
But I say with my sisters in Iran:
no more.
And I say with them:
Women, to reclaim our rights.
(Applause and cheers)
Life, for the lives unjustly taken.
(Applause)
Freedom, for the liberation of my people.
I stand here with my hair in my hand,
in hope of a future
where no little girl has to wish
she were a man
because she's terrified
that she might drown every day.
(Applause)
Yes, the crackdown is brutal.
And yes, there might not be
a solution inside yet.
But the only thing that can help
create and sustain one is hope.
Sorry.
(Cheers and applause)
The only thing that can help create
and sustain one is hope.
And every single one of us can take
a step and play our part.
I'm standing here speaking to you now.
Many non-Iranians and Iranians outside
of Iran have been signing petitions,
going to protest, putting pressure
on their governments
so that in turn, they put pressure
on the Iranian regime and government.
For the past few months,
I've been speaking
to protesters inside of Iran,
and they tell me
how much it matters to them
that we on the outside
stay informed and engaged.
So let's try our best to make certain
that those of us on the shore
let those at sea know
that we see them,
that we hear their cries.
Thank you for taking a step
towards a future
where freedom is not just
a dream, but a reality.
Not just for women,
but for everyone.
And not just in Iran,
but everywhere.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)